DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN THERE WHAT
HAS BIDEN DONE TO IMPROVE THE
LIVES OF ALL AMERICANS.
DID BIDEN PASS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM?
NO.
DID HE PASS POLICE REFORM?
AFTER BALTIMORE, AFTER FERGUSON,
WHAT DID THEY DO?
NOTHING.
WHO CHANGED IT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP CHANGED IT.
DID BARACK AND JOE CREATE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND STRUGGLING
NEIGHBORHOODS?
NO, THAT WOULD BE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE LESS THAN FOUR YEARS AND
DURING THAT TIME PRECORONAVIRUS
RECORD AFTER RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS,
ASIAN-AMERICANS AND
AFRICAN-AMERICAN YOUTH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT IS GREAT FOR OUR COLLECTIVE
AMERICAN FAMILY.
RECENTLY, THE PRESIDENT TOOK
IMPORTANT STEPS TO RESTORE ORDER
IN AMERICAN CITIES INCLUDING
THOSE TOUGH MEASURES AGAINST
VANDALS, THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTING TO TEAR DOWN ANY AND
EVERY STATUE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
BY THE WAY, WHERE DOES JOE STAND
ON THESE ISSUES?
I KNOW TERRY McCULLOUGH WANTS
HIM HANDING IN THE BASEMENT AND
I’M FINE WITH THEM THERE.
ONLY SEEMS TO PEOPLE THAT DAY
AND HE STEPPED OUT, WHAT DID HE
DO?
TALKED ABOUT 120 MILLION
AMERICANS THAT DIED FROM COVID.
WAIT UNTIL YOU SEE OUR MONTAGE
LATER TONIGHT.
DOES HE WANT TO STATUES OF THESE
GENERALS AND LINCOLN AND
JEFFERSON AND WASHINGTON TORN
DOWN?
WHERE DOES JOE STAND ON THIS?
DOES HE SUPPORT PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY STRIPPING THE NAME
WOODROW WILSON FROM ITS
INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT WILSON’S
RACES THINKING?
WHAT ABOUT PLANNED PARENTHOOD?
WE, YOU, THE TAXPAYERS SPENT
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FUNDING PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
IN SHOULD THAT BE RENAMED AS
WELL >> Melissa: BUT FOUNDED
PLAN HIP PARENTHOOD IN THE
EARLIER 20TH CENTURY, WAS A
WELL-KNOWN RACIST AND
EUGENICIST.
GUESS WHAT, ARGUING IN FAVOR OF
POPULATION CONTROL AMONG POOR
PEOPLE.
ALSO, THOSE WITH MENTAL AND
PHYSICAL HANDICAPS AND OTHERS
WHO STRUGGLED IN SOCIETY.
SHE ONCE WROTE "WE DO NOT WANT
THE WORD TO GO OUT THAT WE WANT
TO EXTERMINATE THE [BLEEP]
AFRICAN-AMERICAN POPULATION
THING ONCE TOOK HER MESSAGE OF
POPULATION CONTROL AND PRESENTED
IT GUESS WHERE?
AT A KU KLUX KLAN RALLY.
JOE BIDEN, WHERE DO YOU STAND ON
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND ITS
FOUNDER?
WHERE DO YOU STAND ON THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER FUNDING SUCH
AN ORGANIZATION?
AND BY THE WAY, BUILDING IS
NAMED AFTER HER, WE WANT TO GO
THERE, WHERE DOES JOE STAND
THERE?
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS GAVE AROUND
$600 MILLION TO PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
WHY WOULD TAXPAYERS GIVE A DIME
TO ANY SUCH ORGANIZATION?
WHAT ABOUT THE SENATE BUILDING
NAMED AFTER A PROMINENT DEMOCRAT
ALSO A KNOWN SEGREGATIONIST?
IN THEIR DECADES IN THE CAPITAL,
WHY HAVEN’T BIDEN, PELOSI, AND
SCHUMER, 125 YEARS, WHY HAVEN’T
THEY DONE ANY OF THESE THINGS.
THEN THERE IS THE FORMER
KLANSMAN THAT WAS AHEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR ALL OF
THOSE YEARS, ROBERT BYRD.
BIDEN PRAISED AND EULOGIZED HIS
FORMER COLLEAGUES, BIDEN SAID
THAT HE HELD HIM IN INCREDIBLE
ESTEEM.
CALLED HIM A GREAT AMERICAN
PATRIOT.
ALSO PRAISE ON SENATOR BYRD.
WITHOUT A DOUBT, CD HYPOCRITICAL
HISTORY OF WHAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT THEY WOULD
LIKE AMERICA TO FORGET.
FOR EXAMPLE, BIDEN ONCE WORKED
SIDE-BY-SIDE WITH
SEGREGATIONISTS INCLUDING THE
FORMER KLANSMAN.
DURING A SPEECH IN 1973,
JOE BIDEN PRAISED SOUTHERN
DEMOCRATS AND SAID THAT THE
TWO-PARTY SYSTEM IN THE SOUTH
WAS "GOOD FOR [BLEEP] AND AT THE
SAME TIME, BIDEN WAS ACTIVELY
WORKING TO SLOW INTEGRATION BY
OPPOSING SCHOOL BUSING.
ACCORDING TO NBC NEWS, "HE LED
THE CHARGE ON AN ISSUE THAT KEPT
BLACK STUDENTS AWAY FROM
CLASSROOMS OF WHITE STUDENTS.
1977, BIDEN WORRIED HIS CHILDREN
WOULD GROW UP IN HIS WORDS A
RACIAL JUNGLE IF INTEGRATION
ISN’T DONE IN AN ORDERLY WAY.
1993, REFERRED TO INNER-CITY
YOUNG PEOPLE AS PREDATORS ON THE
STREETS.
AND WRAPPED UP PRISON SENTENCES
FOR DOZENS OF CRIMES, THAT’S
WHERE A LOT OF SENTENCING CAME
IN THE PLAY AND THAT’S WHAT
DONALD TRUMP FIXED.
THAT DIDN’T STOP IN THE 90s,
2,006, THE ONE THAT SAID YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A SLIGHT INDIAN
ACCENT IF YOU WANT TO WORK AT A
7-ELEVEN OR DUNKIN’ DONUTS.
HE ALSO BRACKETED HIS STATE
DELAWARE WAS A STATE.
HE ALSO SAID ABOUT BARACK OBAMA
THIS IS THE FIRST, THE FIRST
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN WHO
IS ACTUALLY ARTICULATE, BRIGHT,
AND CLEAN.
SAID IT IS STORYBOOK, HIS WORDS.
2019, HE BRAGGED ABOUT HIS WORK
WITH SEGREGATIONISTS TO GET
THINGS DONE IN THE U.S. SENATE.
LAST YEAR, HE SAID "POOR KIDS
CAN BE JUST AS BRIGHT AS WHITE
KIDS."
OKAY.
WEEKS AGO, BIDEN TOLD A RADIO
HOST YOU AIN’T BLACK AND LESS
YOU ARE SUPPORTING HIM OVER
DONALD TRUMP.
PRETTY OBVIOUS WHY HE SPENT ALL
OF THAT TIME IN HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER BECAUSE EVERY TIME HE
POPS HIS HEAD OUT, HE CAN BARELY
STRING TWO SENTENCES TOGETHER.
HE IS CONSTANTLY MAKING WEIRD
STATEMENTS, MANY OF THEM RACIAL
IN NATURE AND IT’S ONLY GETTING
WORSE AS BIDEN AGES.
IS HE REALLY FIT TO SERVE AS A
COMMANDER IN CHIEF?
ASKING THIS QUESTION IN 1984
ABOUT RONALD REAGAN, BUT DOES
JOE BIDEN HAVE THE MENTAL
ALERTNESS DOES HE HAVE THE
STAMINA, DOES HE HAVE THE
STRENGTH TO TAKE ON WHAT IS THE
HARDEST JOB IN THE WORLD AND
WHAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN HE
FINALLY HAS TO LEAVE HIS
BASEMENT BUNKER FOR GOOD AND
WHEN WILL THE MEDIA AFTER 88
DAYS WITHOUT A PRESS CONFERENCE
START DEMANDING THAT HE DO SO?
OF POLL JUST OUT SHOWS 38% OF
ALL VOTERS THINK THAT BIDEN HAS
SOME FORM OF DEMENTIA AND THAT
INCLUDES 20% OF DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS.
WILL THE MOB AND THE MEDIA ASKED
BIDEN THE SAME QUESTIONS THEY
ASKED REAGAN ABOUT AGE AND
MENTAL ACUITY?